the pandemic made many of us more
comfortable buying big-ticket items like
cars online but what about renting out
your own car we connect with an expert
on the pros and cons
people were kind of moving towards
becoming
online purchasers of big ticket items
and whatever curve we were on it seems
to have steepened
due to the pandemic grant fee is the ceo
of tread.com it launched in seattle six
years ago and this week expanded to las
vegas it's a used car marketplace
available in about 25 major cities that
allows buyers and sellers to work out
the details of a sale but avoid the
hassle of going to a dealership or the
dmv
while his business is surging so too is
the car rental business gen z and
millennials are driving the growth of
online car rental services like turo get
around and zip car to name a few if you
are working from home and have a car
you're not using feek says you want to
take the following into consideration
before renting out your car with any of
these services i would say that if you
are interested in supplementing your
income
you know depending on the vehicle you
have and its popularity and how you
price it you certainly can make you know
enough money to cover your car payment
by by renting it out the flip side to
that of course is you are further
depreciating your vehicle you also never
know how someone is going to treat your
vehicle plus the fewer owners and users
of a vehicle the better for value and
depreciation but if you can put up with
those concerns he says it might be a
good option for you